another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with a foundation dr  bright is not allowed to violate the scp  foundation dress code nor encourage  others to do so even on casual fridays a  note appended to this rule reads no  matter how many times you say please dr  bright we won't put any of the hats  you've been asking about into the dress  code and the list of hats that dr bright  has facetiously requested has been  nothing short of impressive including a  freakishly tall white doug  dimmadome-esque  hat and a novelty propeller hat with  actual functioning helicopter propellers  a number of other hats he suggested  simple non-anomalous baseball caps with  humorous slogans printed on them have  been deemed to be hr violations sorry  jack